and the spirit award for best new
non-scripted or documentary series goes
to
black and missing
[Applause]
this is executive producers soledad
o'brien and pizza gone beers first
nomination and win the series highlights
the black and missing foundation which
is a non-profit that brings awareness to
missing persons of color
[Music]
what an
incredible honor we have a few folks we
need to thank um so
uh i have to say considering everybody
we were in the category with this is a
really huge honor um we're with we're up
against friends and colleagues who we
admire so much so thank you what makes
this an even bigger bigger honor is this
is a woman-led team and particularly run
entirely directed directed and produced
by majority bipoc women so black and
brown women and you know we're hoping to
set an example here for what is so
important we'd really love to thank um
first natalie and derek wilson who run
the foundation black and missing who are
two black women who again like so many
um saw that there was a gap in
care for their community and just said
you know what screw it we'll do it
because nobody else is paying any
attention so
that you know they first and foremost
are the inspiration for this film we'd
love to thank also hbo documentary films
for believing in this project
nancy lisa and sarah rodriguez who is
with us through the entire process the
entire team at sob films and
patrick and joe who are right behind us
and we're with us also all the way our
directors some fierce black women and
brown women as well uh yoruba richard
nadia halgren
and samantha knowles
we had the
amazing team of producers and editors i
want to reach out to dimco kayla
i want to also say our editors alex
will ulrich and our dps assad and nelson
i think this series proves that people
care about these stories and not just
black people all people care about the
stories that are often ignored and go
untold and undertold because
it's about the humanity of the people
that you profile and so i think
journalists and storytellers generally
have a tremendous opportunity to tell
these stories center people in these
stories and then of course
make sure you have a diverse staff
that actually executes on these stories
it is not magic it's not it's just
deciding to hold yourself accountable to
do that very thing we are so grateful we
are so honored thank you
thank you so much